her game um but a solid start making a
draw in her debut on the
champions chess tour magnus meanwhile
did lose his game so we have started
with the queen's pawn
magnus we know his strategy he's going
to stop who you fan he's going to try at
least
to stop her playing active chess so we
see the queen's gambit
so far the queen's gambit declined will
black capture that gambited pawn
will black just develop um plenty of
moves this position
is extremely well known black has at
least six or seven very logical moves
here but she plays the most direct
ivanka said it that's her style she
pushes a pawn creating
maximum tension in the center and yeah
historically i think she's played magnus
five times in classical chess
lost five times unfortunately but um
some very very close games there i think
magnus normally
his wins have been due to tricking her
in the end game or maybe just eventually
grinding her down
so who you found her best chances do lie
in the middle game if she can keep
tension
physical uh education but not only that
she was actually studying in oxford
university
and we have a move pawn captures the
pawn
bishop takes pawn very quick reply from
magnus and
born moving to the edge of the board
and now uh well it's kind of clear black
wants to expand as much as possible with
the pawns
on the left side of the board uh
dramatic finals
uh throughout the tour and right now i
was about to say he's gonna play pawn
takes pawn and he's gonna swap those
queens he's gonna trade the queens off
the board
because he knows he's playing a very
attacking player a very dynamic player
and magnus he likes to target his
opponent's weaknesses
the queens are off the board black's
queen is just captured white recaptures
so it's completely level in terms of
material in terms of pawn structure it's
pretty balanced no
big weaknesses no double pawns isolated
pawns but magnus is a master at
maneuvering yeah once the queens are off
the board
start upping the speed okay she brings
her knight to a very healthy square
there
and improving her pieces now it's
magnus's turn and he plays
very quickly just moves his knight to
his desired location
open up your rook in the corner that
there we go
while the iron is hot and i noticed
magnus he always plays this move as soon
as black's dark square bishop
lands on that square very thematic very
well known idea magnus won't even think
here
i guarantee it he'll just okay looks
like his camera is frozen
so maybe he will think uh if he's lost
connection but okay he's just gonna push
his pawn forward even more
uh one square further he's to ignore the
threat on this night right now
go back and uh yeah pretty much played
very quickly so what is your favorite
travel destination in asia and why make
us jealous yes
exactly the winner will be the one who
makes us the most jealous
that's a really bad track record for
black and this move
that david recommended magnus has just
played
it's a top move and white has won all
their games out too many games
white has won every single one of them
too great for black right now
white has a simple move white tonight
okay the knight that was attacked has
jumped in
the other knight could have jumped in as
well the knights now protecting each
other
and look at black's pawns on the left
side of the board that knight is
actually attacking a pawn already
in conjunction with white's white
light-squared bishop along the diagonal
so already
that has some serious questions to
answer um
yeah mate can black just remove okay i
was gonna say
can can black be greedy and snap over
porn
in fact i was gonna warn against it then
i realized it was actually possible it's
possible
it's possible right that's why we were
both uh we were both expecting right
magnus to use his other knight to jump
into that square to keep that pawn that
has just been captured
to keep that protected because that pawn
for white it doesn't look too important
it looks like black bishop's a bit
offside having captured it but that pawn
for white
was a potential game winner if more
pawns get traded off the board as long
as black doesn't lose any pieces
if white doesn't have pawns you're never
going to win the game in an end game
past pawns are the currency
that's the best way to win and that type
of move for me i would be spending two
or three
minutes on it just thinking is it
possible has my opponent kind of lured
me forward to capture a porn is it kind
of a
trick is it a trap but no magnus has
showed he wasn't expecting it he's just
had to develop his bishop
white's currently down the pawn can you
see can you castle because if you can't
castle
uh okay you ready ivanka you who you
found your
psychic connection she castles and
also who you found she's been higher
rated i mean she nearly got to 2 700 not
quite
um but 2 700 that's kind of the golden
super ground master mark
i mean okay i think she's found a good
move activating a rook that wasn't doing
too much but i was about to say the
clock situation
being four or five minutes down against
magnus carson is not where you want to
be especially when older they focus on
other things in life
and uh this is as a consequence mean
that they don't work as hard
but uh okay i don't know i mean there's
so many things and uh
let's uh get back to the action because
we certainly
saw something happening there what is
your favorite travel destination in asia
and why
and wait one second that's gonna have to
hold because
the move that you suggested is don't
play
it's on the board yeah she has taken
that knight
so she's one step closer to her goal of
just trading off all the pieces but
now look white did have that bad night
on the edge of the board but by trading
you've traded off a decent night for
black
but you've traded off four black four
white terrible knight
on the side of the board so suddenly
white's rook in the corner is happy
white doesn't have a problem piece
anymore black's still stuck
with the bad bishop on the edge of the
board there and
now she has to deal with that problem
who you find how is she going to improve
her black bishop stuck there protecting
a pawn
also there's going to be tricks look at
black's back rank as well it's extremely
weak
black's rook in the corner kind of
defended by the bishop in the middle but
it's all looking very shaky very loose
for black right now white rooks on open
lines very comfortable white has a very
powerful knight right now
and it feels okay she just gives her
king some breathing space so there's
not going to be any checkmates on the
back rank that's a very sensible move by
who you fan
open up diagonals towards your king but
if you are
able to push that pawn later on that
would be fantastic so
um okay let's go back to the position
instead he's pushed his knight to the
side of the board
and okay what's happening here black has
to take the rooks there's a double
threat now rook takes bishop and knight
takes rook you have to
um solve this tension so you have to
trade rooks now earlier we criticized
who you found for trading but she has to
take this rook she has done
and now the problem is this bishop you
have to deal with something
you have to deal with it now when i was
a junior when i was a youngster learning
the game playing the game
hundreds of people would walk into this
type of this was the way
on the board it's all aboard david
[Laughter]
yeah this is the most common way that
people lose the game when they first
learn chess so that's why we wanted to
highlight it
end up with a win for magnus it's his
type of position still
so he's guided it to a position that
suits his style that he's got experience
that's quite simplified
he is an end game virtuoso but um huifan
so far she's not backing down she's
still been calculating well
uh she she keeps kind of finding herself
in awkward situations then finding a way
out of it and that's the key thing in
these end games
back it up with some calculation maybe
magnus go for that pawn immediately
because that's
all by itself and uh yeah you see it on
the board
e4 is always a good move do you know
something
really funny i just been reading a book
about the soviet championships from 1920
and there they never ever played the
move e4 okay and then you see it's on
the board and the bishop has moved to
the edge of the look
how bad that bishop is so bad it was a
beautiful piece and
yeah it was like completely the e4 is
for those aggressive players
for the attackers and uh magnus decides
yes he absolutely can capture that pawn
and uh magnus has just been so smooth i
mean in the end game
i mean i thought that he found played
enough to actually cause a lot of
kind of problems to the world champion
yeah i mean she was dealing with
everything he threw at her
right but just i think maybe allowing
that bishop to get kicked back into the
corner
and there we have a move rook moves
backwards and magnus just goes i'm going
to go forward you go backwards i go
forward
if you played it instantly he's putting
the pressure on the clock that's a
dangerous pre-move you never do that
kind of stuff
buy a white piece and um yeah if you
don't okay
first magnus goes for maybe the safe
option he just
eliminates the black knight i didn't
think that was necessary but knights
they're tricky pieces in speeches
so getting rid of it white tonight
dominates the black bishop and now that
pawn is marching
and it's going to much one more step oh
and you can just see with
you can just see it there on who you
found camera she knows it's all over
yeah and uh now there's only one square
that the rook can move to and it's just
to
step in front of its king not good
step in front of his king no and i'm
just look to okay i didn't even see
that's possible i assumed
uh hugh fan would choose this square for
her rook um
so it was impossible to go after white's
pawn there because black's bishop was
trapped in the corner
black had to move that bishop but now
there's a there's tactics
there's tricks yeah white is now
attacking that black bishop that black
bishop has no safe squares
huyifan now has to just give up her
bishop if she takes that white pawn
white's rook will slide across one
square
and pin that bishop but if she moves
that ro that bishop from the diagonal
hey
what is going to move the rook two
squares up and uh well that's it
she resigns about to lose her bishop who
you fan gives up
it's uh over magnus carlsen getting a
win